[Music]
whoa
welcome to the break room our daily show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news baby i'm not as good as back with
the segways oh guys that was good i
don't know that wasn't a segue
muscles gone too far not in my book
never in my book not until they've gone
all the way up my ass look at the
muscles
yes
yeah and there you go thank you uh bezos
shows off his hard foots i don't like
that i have to say that joke daschle and
we talk about a war that's very secret
it's a war secret
united states a lot of those today's
redemption is still gotta
kick me out
today's redemptions is still thorough
themed for every hundred dollars you
know we're going to be swearing up a
storm in that great viking uh curse
words from back in the day some don't
seem as cursey as the others but so far
so much
um and if we break a thousand by the end
of the day friday so we got till
tomorrow end today
we're shaving tommy yeah
head to toe
head to dope head to toe head to toe
head to toe we're gonna shave tommy on
air uh and you guys get to vote we have
four haircuts and you guys get the vote
in the poll we don't get to decide you
guys get to decide we're very close to
that goal but there is a goal beyond
that just what's the goal beyond it if
we get to two thousand dollars
i we haven't maybe explained this
properly we're not just going to see
minions rise of groove we are doing the
gentle minions challenge the challenge
that has like this one tortured
movie theater
employees
but we're not going to dis we disrespect
no no i just don't want to get put on a
list yeah
we're gonna we're gonna get we're gonna
put on our sunday best and we're gonna
go and see uh yeah we're gonna video
ourselves walking in our suits and ties
and dresses and thighs uh to see the
gentle minions uh to see the
uh minions rise of crew so that's two
thousand dollars guys camera four real
quick
we're a ways away from that your
cheapskates okay we're not even close to
me getting a haircut you see this hair
nobody likes definitely need to raise
the thousand for the week for tommy's
hair listen let's get there soon because
honestly if we're not around like 900 by
the end of today i'm not calling a
barber okay
i'm not gonna waste my time do you know
how much influence i have in this town
if i call a barber 50 barbers are gonna
show up here and we're going to have
like a barber shop quartet but it's
going to be whatever 50 is someone's
donating 10 oh chrissy come on chrissy
don't help don't encourage me
tommy you need a shave we need you
trimmed from throat to scrote that's
right you cleaned up i want to be able
to wear a tommy wig by the end of the
week
yes ma'am we will be making wigs out of
my hair for everyone on the show oh my
god and uh where are my manners today we
have erica woo soon
everybody
i also think this person's very fitting
tommy bechtel hi everyone so great to be
back on the break room i'm so honored to
be here so
so blessed to get to share this time
with you our wonderful
wonderful viewers who are not garbage
people who don't smell bad who have
perfectly aligned teeth uh
and are not married to their cousins
okay everything that i said before was
all a big joke but i didn't mean any of
it okay so thank you so much for tuning
in and uh
between you and me
you better start donating money okay or
i'm gonna come to your house i don't you
guys don't know this i do reverse
searches on everybody's names and i pay
that 5.99 on google i know where you all
live and i'm gonna start showing up at
your house oh my gosh and last but not
least after that horrible horrible
threat brandon barry
so happy to be here as always and we
thank you all for being here uh
uh and you're right for a girl it is too
bad that man escaping's not sponsoring
this week because we gotta clean tommy
up he's gotta be escaped like a man uh
but we have other great sponsors for the
show this week that we will get to a
little bit later but before that fun
stuff we gotta talk about our headlines
[Applause]
oh baby our first headline miss marvel
has ended its inaugural season as the
highest rated project from marvel
studios to date this includes series or
shows uh or movies or whatever books uh
they put out a line of fine china that
you can have for your wedding it's
beautiful uh right now this marvel has a
98 certified fresh rating on rotten
tomatoes if you ascribe to a service
like rotten tomatoes i don't always
trust them but it's got a very high
rating uh and this score bested the
previous high of 96 percent held by
black panther uh yep yep so yeah the
critics love it the people love it that
dare to watch it some of you scaredy
cats out there don't want to watch it uh
but it's a great show it's been one of
my favorite series for sure i love the
finale finale was phenomenal the as i
said yesterday the the fight the final
battle scene if you will between uh
between our heroes and the dreaded dodc
i thought was very moving i like the
inclusion as usual uh marvel does a
great job of including the common
citizens in the battle with the heroes
and i enjoyed that for you like to keep
us safe those heroes yeah
no i i really enjoyed miss marvel you
know
don't get caught up in all the
jibber-jabber online about it who cares
what people think just watch the shows
that you like
don't like a show don't watch it move on
with your life yeah uh but yeah next
headline hey the mid credits scene from
episode six of miss marvel brought brie
larson's carol danvers back to earth uh
complete with her fourth new costume in
the marvel cinematic universe
uh we're gonna have more details about
that and like her jewelry and our break
room breakdown later today but we do
have like uh a picture of like yeah this
was kind of like a good look at her new
outfit uh
uh it's kind of similar to her previous
one she got rid of the sleeves you know
maybe she's going for that uh that
falcon look he never wore sleeves why
should she have to wear something i did
think it was interesting datsun pointed
this out too her like little pattern on
her side
uh the like the the stomach area of the
suit it kind of looks like the fabric on
kamala's suit
a little bit kind of like cube design
the stuff they got from uh hidden in the
toffee boxes yeah yes which her mom's
making the suit from drawing fabrics or
whatever's in the top boxes yeah why is
carol danvers suit like a look a little
bit similar
maybe it's part of that cree sleeper
cell we know is in america maybe they're
fabricators maybe they're maybe it's a
fashion house cree house
house of crete awesome going to disney
plus we get to switch make it work are
we going to swear
we should stop the show immediately to
answer that question mls speeds msls
mlsp
mid speeds uh well their question was
call in and tell us how you say what's
your favorite ranking of marvel disney
plus shows love you guys oh what is your
ranking um division is still always
gonna be that's hard
loki is number one for me loki's one for
i did like the look of loki a lot it was
very stylish
mine goes i'm gonna do three one
division
loki oh
yeah one division loki
oh this is our one division one division
loki moon night yeah
i'm sorry it was hard because i was like
miss marvel's in my top three but i love
moon night oh my god
i go loki
then i go taiwan division moon night and
then i go miss marvel yeah then i go
falcon and winter soldier and then i go
oh card
i love hawker i loved all these shows i
love a christmas movie so as a christmas
movie hawkeye's right right soundtrack
let me just be honest with you i uh
mt gets mad if any of us show any
affinity towards haley steinfeld so i
avoided hawkeye because i'm afraid of mt
he's a powerful man and he's very well
connected in the boston mafia so it's
very true yeah
like a different
things
i
which is i know i said this wrong but
it's the balls oh yeah well if you keep
being you i'm gonna
uh
did
which is clean hands in vikings
i i'm going to say a big
dosh jin
which is [ __ ] you
thanks to chrissy
chrissy who sent that in to us so i'm
going to say
dash chen to all the haters out there
but not to our audience who has most
definitely showered today and uh has
gone to their local target or grocery
store to buy deodorant in the last
calendar month you guys are clean you're
not garbage
and people i love you all very much but
dodge tent to my haters well you all
keep bringing like a bunch of bruisy
which are he goats oh i don't know what
a she-goat is but now we know what he
got it's a bruha
hey in an interview with inverse
[Laughter]
legendary marvel costume designer graham
churchill teased how the costume design
particularly uh her progress pin pointed
sorry her progress pin point to america
chavez's lgbtq plus journey in the mcu
uh he was encouraged to add the project
progress pin by richie palmer a former
marvel production assistant who has
since graduated to development and is
getting his name out there this week
producer john sees his name everywhere
uh this is of course so we're talking
about america's chavez's costume she's
got the little progress pin you may have
noticed it's on the action figures i
guess there was like a lot more to her
costume it had like a bunch of graffiti
and like spanish language poetry on it
which some of it's still there it's like
a little hard to see i think raymie was
like let's tone this down a little bit
it's a little it's a lot going on on the
screen uh but you know they're kind of
saying that there's a future for this
storyline and that the pin means
something more than just having a pin on
the costume which i think is great uh
and excited to see where that go that
goes richie palmer had said uh yeah do
it put it on uh he said it allows a it
allows enough to be shown where the
character is going in the mcu so maybe
they got some plans for that in the
future they had a big meeting for the
next 10 years so i'm sure they'll talk
about it more as we keep going next
headline hey in an interview with usa
today
chris hemsworth revealed that elsa
pataki elsa pataki that's how you spell
helga pataki so yes oh fun
no relationship didn't exactly love the
bulging biceps on the god of thunder uh
this is what hemsworth had to say he
said quote my wife was like bleh it's
too much hemsworth revealed uh there are
a lot of my male friends who are like
yeah but a lot of female friends and
family are like yuck
that's why i got rid of my muscles me
too too many complaints yeah i'm still
in the bulking phase but i'm going to
cut soon you don't like veins yeah yeah
i want well doctors for him to just look
like a ball of muscle
i love it he did look like a ball i feel
like we've been getting a lot of lies
from the hemsworth family lately
yesterday hemsworth lied about going
vegan to kiss natalie portman and i feel
like now his wife is like it's probably
due to the fact i i wonder maybe this is
sexist and i can feel free to call me
out on this well i'm sexist do you think
perhaps she just didn't enjoy how much
time it took to look like that and how
much time away from their family and
their children to look like that and
because when you are that like when you
when your body is your work
you have to it's a lifestyle thing the
way you eat the way you sleep everything
you i i know obviously
but it is it's a full-time job she's
also a model and fitness trainer yeah
okay
i'll just go
check myself then probably yeah no but
this is an episode of um actually right
oh no yes
you just did you just man
what i read in the news i'm joking i'm
joking the house probably smells like
steamed broccoli oh my god oh my god
boiled chicken's team
too much next headline hey folks we got
a new lord of the rings trailer today
we're not going to show you the full two
and a half minutes but here's a quick
little snippet of it if you haven't seen
it yet go ahead and roll that uh daschle
there was a time when the world was so
young
[Music]
there had not yet been a sunrise
but even then
there was light
call to me calls
[Music]
about no dwarfs
are we excited for the rings as someone
who hates reading i have no idea what
happens in this story so i'm excited to
learn all about it i saw the movies once
wow
but that's my blind spot in nerd dumb is
definitely the lord of the rings i
couldn't i couldn't do it it was too
much reading for my dumb dumb brains
i read the hobbit when i was really
young because my brother i remember was
like you don't know
so i did it my brother was like
reading yeah brainy bullying well well
we'll get back to bullying later but now
this makes sense as to why we're so
heavy into bullying oh no
and i like the second movie the most to
like everyone else
behind the scenes here joshua is super
hyped for lord of the rings uh we're
trying we want a guy for it too we're
excited to come for it here on the
channel i think this series is gonna be
great just the little bit we got to see
there
tons of vistas tons of different uh
cultures and species olivia rodriguez
olivia rodriguez
you said forever now there's sunlight
coming from a tree oh my god you guys
did you just
orcs now
i still see some elves with a bow and an
arrow
someone shaved this man
the russo brothers did a video uh
called i don't complete with uh sorry
the russo brothers did a video interview
with uh wired in their auto complete
series uh and they were asked what they
would do if they directed justice league
and they said just watch the snyder cut
it's all there who's asking these
questions like why are people doing this
stop trying to pick directors against
each other yes uh that's fine but it was
nice to be like we're not touching the
movie it's been
filmed enough times and edited enough
time yeah move on okay but in the same
interview they also jokingly address why
some fans think they quote nerfed the
hulk in infinity war and in game uh they
said quote he deserved it but then at it
it was really they didn't know what to
do with this big powerful character and
that's so true we were talking about
that the other day like you can't just
have the hulk the hulk is like a tough
character because he is so unstoppable
and uh powerful and even in the comics
he's constantly nerfed constantly nerfed
to the comics
because it's always like oh you can't
like if the hulk can't run out of air
but people like make him pass out all
the time right
he's constantly getting knocked out in a
fight even though he's not supposed to
be able to be knocked out i don't know
get off it yeah
okay
you're just reading all the comments
my cat's dead yeah everyone's like
a lot of people feel like my singing
voice may have harmed their cats i
thought the thing was always that cats
had bad singing voices no cat you've
seen cats cats
i did not realize i was going to touch
on such a sensitive narrative on the
show
we asked you guys in the chat do you
like miss marvel more than black panther
uh 58 of you said black panther uh
what's your favorite why did we ask that
question i have no idea
what's your favorite captain marvel suit
let's get the two shows that focus
which one they're not pitted against
each other which do you prefer
all right guys what do you like better a
white captain america
we gotta know now we're getting into the
mgu guys oh my gosh listen time to make
her story i'm not sure
i'm just reading the poem
48 like the new one sorry
uh
82 of you think thor's body was too much
what's wrong with you oh because they're
the highest rated sorry i have to clear
dodson's good name they're the highest
rated disney he wasn't trying to start a
culture war don't worry i just read it
me jerk i thought maybe a fan wrote it
in i don't know we got some weird fans
out there someone sent me their hair the
other day and they said put it on your
own head of hair don't ever get a
haircut someone shaved this man i don't
want you someone's you want me to go
yeah please get us out of here the russo
brothers share with deadline their
future dream marvel movie uh do we have
a little clip for it
our love for marvel is based on the
books that we read as kids and the books
that we fell in love with the one series
that you know we adored uh growing up
with secret wars it's incredibly
ambitious it would be bigger than
anthony warren end game but it's a
massive undertaking
and uh you know those those two movies
were you know very very hard to make so
trying to imagine making another two
movies even bigger than those two
uh you know
we're gonna have to sleep on it
they're gonna have to sleep on do you
think they sleep on like bunk beds
absolutely i don't know they might be
sharing a twin
shirt
they're married
they're married to each other
some states in some states
if they live together in that twin bed
long enough in california technically
they're married come along common law i
think i think when they have to come up
with a new script they go to they go to
their twin room and they're at twins
they go to their their sibling room and
they sleep in a double decker bar that's
right the idea of making like a pillow
floor yeah and being like okay so secret
awards how are we going to speak how are
we going to break it down let's break it
down
joe
joe are you are you awake yes anthony
what do you want i have a crush on
secret wars don't tell him don't tell
him don't tell him
don't tell him don't so what's the
likelihood now i feel like we everyone's
uh kevin feige's even mentioned secret
wars yeah everyone's been talking about
secret wars stick wars seek war
so it's marshall marshall marsha it's
the exact same thing so what's the
likelihood of them doing secret words do
you think it's going to happen no it's a
red herring you think it's a they're
going this way it's going to be a hard
pivot this is what they're just the
shiny new ball that they're throwing out
there to throw us off the trail but it's
it's not gonna be secret yeah oh my god
you know what i said
good for you i hope you make your dumb
movie who cares why not just make house
of man hey
no house of am stay away from um
stay away from me but come forward but
they were they so they were at the
premiere of their new movie the great
man
and i hope they had a great carpet at
that premiere yeah
uh and they were asked about this
as we know right now like the russo
brothers have no new projects lined up
for marvel they don't have anything like
in the pipe for marvel i will say like
secret wars if they do do it it is a
good way to bring in like you could
bring chris evans back as a captain
america from another
universe you could bring uh robert
downey jr back as iron man from another
universe uh you could kind of have some
of these people come back in like a fun
way without fully bringing them back
i mean that goes into my second point
where they i think a really big takeaway
from that interview is them saying two
yeah they said two they said they did
two then they need to uh be bigger and
better than what they did before so they
are gonna stretch secret wars into being
two movies so that clearly secret wars
would be our end goal i think it would
be like more than two movies i think the
ambitious thing would be to do like
a weird three movie or four movie set of
like this is secret word or movie i mean
why not if they're making like all of
these tv shows and you can kind of keep
the the thing moving with the tv shows
and make your movies just the big tent
poles
why not do like four of them who cares
they do whatever they want they can do
whatever they want make it a quad do it
like avatar i do think whether or not
they're gonna actually do secret wars i
think uh because uh producer jonathan
pointed out that like even right after
end game they were kind of talking about
secret wars like oh we'd love to do that
too
uh
i think them just constantly saying in
interviews is that i'm like calling dibs
in a weird way
no one touched this uh this is ours so
when all these new writers and stuff are
submitting ideas to marvel no one dares
touch secret words it's like
people in the chat are saying it needs
to be a trilogy
it should be more than two movies i
meant no should be three or four okay
thank you groom reaper uh three movies
each three hours you guys want nine
hours you guys want a three okay i mean
how would that even look it would just
be like the lord of the rings yeah so it
would come out okay would it so they
wouldn't be coming out with any other
movie at this time they would unless
it's like you know how like like
captain marvel like in between yeah
infinity award and gameplay
heroes were taken off of her yeah to
like another planet the newer one the
2015 was more of like an incursion where
like yeah all these earths get merged
and you have battle world and like
everything gets rearranged in the same
space if it's a situation where heroes
are plucked and taken away you could
still have movies take place on earth
sure with the heroes that are just don't
have the here involved in secret wars
okay i like that and i also like oh my
gosh it went by so quickly someone said
that it should be its own phase and i
would love that a secret phrase a secret
a secret face
i had a secret phase back in college
what was it
oh it's a secret oh
the future is you you all your whole
life your job is just watching secret
wars marvel and disney find a way to pay
you to watch it you wake up in the
morning you watch secret wars all day
you go to bed and it's uh 17 000 movies
stretched over the rest of your life yes
there's so many characters in secret
wars in both the early like 60s 70s one
and the 2015 one do you think we need to
get to a point where we have not only
deadpool but like wolverine we have the
experts
we have to have everybody in right you
don't want to just i feel like it's easy
to do it prematurely yeah secret wars i
want we have to have everybody right if
it's their like long tail
project right
and right now is the time of like making
the multiverse making different
timelines making different dimensions
and secret wars is a good way to like
kill all of them right so if the final
that that could be their end game uh is
is if they're gonna if they're making
all these timelines and stuff and
starting to get messy the ending to it
the way to bring it all back to a new
starting point would be like secret wars
where you kind of wipe things out and
you start with a new fresh universe
where you have miles morales from a
different universe and you have peter
parker and you have
uh whomever from another universe all
mixed together they did really well with
endgame and infinity war that i would
need to see a lot more deaths in secret
wars secret war is dead it is yeah
everyone dies uh spider-man
again like everyone dies in secret wars
at least once so it's like even doctor
strange did as a sheriff so it's like
you gotta kill everybody it would be fun
it would be fun to have them like kill
out more more fun
that'd be a lot of fun you really enjoy
it i feel like whatever is going on with
the russo brothers their plans will
remain
a secret oh boy oh my god stop loving it
do uh do we lastly i got do we do we
want this
i feel like
do we want no no i meant to say like
thinking of how i'm gonna phrase this
question miss uh miss marvel was aligned
with the comics for sure but i think it
was more so not i think they were like
oh we need to recognize that the tv
shows and the movies they can't align
completely with the comics but sometimes
they need to take people out of that
because not everyone's reading the
comics so with that being said do you
think secret wars has to stay on the
line of the comics exactly nothing
should be direct from the comments yeah
right i think i think they've learned
that they don't need to do that they've
spent 15 years doing backstory they
don't need
i i don't want to know things that are
going to happen in movies i like what it
deviates from the comments because it's
a surprise and it's shocking and it's
different like i love that they were
like oh here's the scroll but they're
good
because they've been trained to hate the
squad yeah if you've ever read a comic
book it's just scroll hatred forever
yeah uh but they started off with being
like no the squirrels are actually nice
now there's gonna be some bad stuff
but yeah i make it different from the
comics completely different oh sorry i
did say i think it's in the 2015 run
where
they call him sheriff doctor strange and
he is like the cop
of the uh of the 2015 run in um secret
wars the battle world uh yes
uh i remember him i don't remember if he
did have a badge or if i force myself to
remember it but i do remember when he
gets killed everyone's like where is
sheriff strange
um
it's it's crazy uh you guys let us know
in the chat who you want to see in
secret wars tell me if you really do
want to see this movie be five movies
plus i mean we did run a poll 85 percent
said it should be two movies yeah and i
think yeah no one wants them to rush it
that was my problem with civil war it
was like it was so rushed
that's such a big comic book event to do
it and one movie was like yeah and it
was a captain america technically filmed
it was like captain america asterick
film yeah uh definitely felt more like
an avengers movie yes uh yeah okay so
we'll have to wait and see but i think
i think it's a good way to to
reset when they need to reset i'll tell
you
brothers are the people that i want to
take it off absolutely i don't think if
i i don't want anyone else to yeah
i don't know i trust them enough and i
and everyone's talking about secret wars
and if they do bring back the silver
surfer i want him to be the one in
charge of it
and i want him to be played by
[Music]
frankie muniz
now if they are gonna if they're gonna
have all those characters they're gonna
have a lot of people they're gonna want
to feed lunch too so why not call
hellofresh shout out to our friends at
hellofresh america's number one meal kit
for a reason baby they're sending out
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients
seasonal recipes right to your door
steps select the meals from the taste of
summer series that are sure to become
everyone's favorites like the old bay
shrimp and sausage boil and family style
grilled steak lettuce wraps no wrapping
in tortillas you wrap it up in lettuce
you put the lettuce inside the steak or
the steak inside the lettuce dealer's
choice where i'm from you can also
customize your favorite dishes with
hello custom by swapping out one protein
for another upgrading for a more luxe
experience or even adding protein to a
veggie meal unless you're chris
hemsworth in which case
if it's kitchen day no the only protein
you're getting is bean protein that
means more choices more variety and more
meals truly tailored to you
i made
a seared pork chop sirloin steakhouse
style pork chop last night i believe we
have some footage that is gonna roll
there's the potatoes there's the cut
potatoes coming up there they are look
at that slicing and dicing you guys i'm
no cook oh i'm no cook
but what i can do
is pat down a pork chop like no other
honestly it's blown out
it's a high the white balance is a
little off well you know what my
girlfriend's house and her kitchen is
the center of the sun oh
and there's me searing those choppers i
got to be honest the one thing i can't
master is the potatoes and i feel like
those are the easiest thing to cook so
call in with your potato half were you
were you baking the potatoes what i do
is i just put it on top of the hood of
my car oh yeah
that's your first problem yeah and then
i rev my engine up look at that though
what is that sitting on top of what's
that
oh it's a plate
oh sorry well it's a little blown out
jess because sorry that we didn't have
our full new rockstars crew there
filming my dinner last night hello fresh
market is a one-stop shop for all your
judge not judged mealtime needs with
quick breakfast lunches snacks and
desserts and more for if you're not a
hater like jessica go to hellofresh.com
break room 16 and use code break room 16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts unless you're jessica in which you
don't deserve a gift that's code break
room 16 for up to 16 free meals and
three gifts for anyone but jessica
clemens
and christy she said you use too much
oil
generous
i like a lot of you want a nice sear on
it
no
that's good yeah
hey we also want to thank our friends at
athletic greens tommy has been using
athletic cranes i like using athletic
greens especially their ag-1 uh it gives
you better gut health and more energy uh
you've been on it for a couple months
now you love it i've been taking it i
love it hey look at this
boom beautiful stuff all you need is one
delicious scoop of eg1 a little bit of
water uh and it's got 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole foods source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right i don't
know what you're laughing at jessica i'm
not loving anything
this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging uh i i was
recently on a trip and i loved having
the travel packs yes with me
helping me sleep get on a good sleep
cycle in a new time zone it's very great
uh hg1 contains less than one gram of
sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals are
artificial anything and you know what it
tastes pretty good uh especially for a
green liquid it tastes really good
sometimes you get a green liquid and it
tastes like it's a green liquid yeah but
this is good stuff right now it's your
time to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop and a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
don't have them scattered around your
kitchen like a maniac you forgot what
you took you're not sure your piece
smells weird you don't need all that to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you yes you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first person
purchase these delicious little bad boys
you don't even got to measure it out you
can do it in the dark
that's right who cares uh all you got to
do is go to athleticgreens.com
break room again that's a athletic
greens.com break room to take ownership
of your health and pick up the ultimate
daily nutritional insurance
[Music]
that's right
make no mistake about it and speaking of
making no mistakes about it it's time
for mandatory fun yeah
haters in the building look at them
credits rolls yes this is the segment so
nice that yesterday we only played the
graphic twice hit it again
ah
but it's a brand new day so we're going
to play the graphics tray hit it again
oh my god they're clamoring for more
give me my graphics four hit it again
young shakespeare ah everyone calling
all the members of the beck hive buzz
buzz buzz here comes the graphic five
hit it
again oh
okay time to get something new into the
mix just kidding number six hit it again
oh you know what there's a new rockstars
editor named devin so let's play this
one for him hit it seven
all right i feel great
hit it again
all right now
uh we in the break room would never
condone bullying right jessica i i don't
bully i don't like what you keep telling
people i do i wrote that in earlier
today and then it came true on the show
however
we do encourage a brand of brutal
suggestions so
we are all gonna take our turn uh
turning our caps backwards wearing
marlboro shirts to school
you know breaking the rules going into
the bathroom giving kids swirlies and uh
we're gonna bully some studio executives
into making the movies and tv that we
want now at the end
our wonderful producer dodson is going
to put all four of our names up in the
chat and you will vote
to see who had the best bullying
and that winner will get to bully the
rest of the cast gently for the rest of
the show
also we are 12 away
from another benchmark another thor
swear and a little bit closer to cutting
my thor hair okay so just saying now
might be the time to give which one of
you brave
soldiers wants to go first and bully
some studio execs
do you want to go first no i'll go first
i'll go first okay
what are you doing
this is what bullies do right there
where it turns out
i wear a headband and i'm not a bully
hey
i'm talking to you disney okay you went
around you bought up a lot of properties
and that's fine i'm okay with that uh
that's good do your thing you've been
doing a great job with some things but
you keep pushing me okay i was promised
a rogue squadron movie where's my rogue
squadron movie you keep pushing it down
pushing the release date
i don't think it's ever going to come
out now i want to see some boys and
girls flying around in their little
spaceships and shooting things i don't
need to see any jedi i don't need to see
any lightsabers i don't need to see
tatooine please no more tatooine i want
to see some people flying around in
space having dog fights with other
spaceships okay that's all i'm asking
for give me wedge antilles kicking ass
and taking names all right show me
perkins before he died show me the life
of perkins okay give me the rogue
squadron give me the rogue squadron what
are you gonna do to them if they don't
give it to you if you don't give it to
me disney i'm gonna come down there and
i'm gonna put thomas jerry thomas johnny
back jobs in all your toilets
jesus do it jesus hey guys jesus christ
i'm a bad boy out of skateboarding
on a skateboard hit me
camera four
i'm on a skateboard cause i'm a bad boy
with nothing to lose and no health
insurance
brian henson
it's me tommy beck told
you have the power to bring dinosaurs
the abc tgis sitcom back
peter jacobson it's 20 22. make the
family diverse maybe robbie is gay i
don't care make him all gay make it a
progressive gay dinosaur family give us
the dinosaurs
not the mama i'm the baby gotta love me
sit in your little creature shop
jerk it off to pictures of dark crystal
and labyrinth no get back to the
dinosaurs go back to the stone age a
simpler time make the dinosaurs great
again only you can do this brian only
you can do this
dinosaurs dinosaurs
dinosaurs
the least smooth dolly in all of
hollywood i can't
i'll go next um you know i don't know
how to look like a bully
um don't brought my skateboard baby like
that okay there you go
look here
but
look here buddy um i think what am i
really really mad about you know what
i'm really mad about and i still have
not lived this down um i'm gonna die i'm
gonna die on this hill look here fox you
cancel shows after one season way too
often you don't even give them a chance
and you have a lot of money you're owned
by disney now i know much [ __ ]
money
give me your lunch money because i know
you got it yeah and i'm so mad and i'm
still gonna die on this hill a firefly
was ended way too soon
you hear me you
the person that wrote orville oh who is
that seth macfarlane in your pocket
literally in your pocket he does
anything you guys ask for him to do let
him do it he would even be in it and i
would love it and we could just make a
reunion special i just need more firefly
it ended too soon i'm 28 years old and
i'm still dying for more firefly and i'm
sure other people are
bring it back fox or i'm gonna
i'm gonna gonna throw some trays of milk
at your head you're not about five i'm
mad about space above and beyond oh yeah
that's an old fox one season
cancellation that needs to come back i'm
mad about earth too
and johnny zero no one remembers that
show i love johnny zero johnny tsunami
which sounds the same
x y aka
no
all right hit me on camera two over
there there we go all right listen here
you disney bastard
y'all need to stop playing all right the
mcu is expanding rapidly you're putting
live action characters in it left or
right we love america chavez we love
with marvel we love moon knight they're
all great
stop playing and give me a goddamn live
action miles morales i'm sick and tired
of y'all pussyfooting around
he gave us donald glover is potentially
his uncle mr prowler you gave us
three spidermen
and no way home
not one of them was black jamie foxx
called y'all out what are you doing in
that movie what about the mention the
message the dimension was there the
mention was there
we need and
uh nam ki is basically ted or ned
in in the tom hollands so miles morales
comic book buddy is basically tom hall
and peter parker's buddy but we don't
have a goddamn live action miles morales
i'm sick of this [ __ ] disney i know
you're in burbank we're right down the
street
we are in burbank i don't know and i
will come down
to the other end of burbank idaho and i
will put a foot so far up mickey mouse's
butt that he will have to spit out some
miles morales choices for this
live-action movie that we need to have
we need it i will do what needs to be
done to get a live-action miles morales
make it happen
spray girl uh
sorry i'm just agreeing with bray girl
scroll up frey girl said it and i and i
agree with it red dwarf oh
they made american red dwarf and it was
bad
it was really bad uh all right we did
get another thor swear so i feel like we
need to honor do something honor our
ancestors while we're waiting for the
pole to finish i believe eric might be
running away with it
what's that mean a glossy [ __ ] it's a
coward
it's true
i am definitely a draghi which means
slowpoke i have moments every once in a
while i thought that was the character
from game of thrones dragon it might
also
was it draggy
no
yeah
i am tick
a female dog wow wolf wow you know what
they say mama hachi mama that's that's
that's that's what's going on
in heat
we have oh results and i believe
correctly erica wins this one yeah
with his uh brilliant
forceful plea for miles morales
for the next 13 to 14 minutes to gently
bully everyone on the show all right you
can do whatever you want i'll do it this
is what i'm going to do i'm not touching
you
that's cool we have our next breakdown i
hate it
now the new breakdown from eric boss
about the possibility of these being
mega bands the bangles
let's see let's take a look
he also does not wear the full red
gauntlet length gloves her forearms are
bare now with shorter wrist length
fingerless gloves also notice kamala's
teleportation just looks different than
you'd expect her body twists into
ribbony putty we haven't seen this kind
of production design in the mcu there's
no glowing portal thank god it's a whole
new design meaning a completely new form
of technology and magic is unfolding
before our eyes and in marvel comics
when characters like nightcrawler
teleport they're actually traveling
through the medium of another dimension
in between those points for nightcrawler
it's the brimstone dimension here i
think it is teleportation through the
negative zone because i think the bengal
is alien cree technology based on the
kree nega bands from captain marvel
comics in those comics the mega bands
were given to captain marvel by the cree
supreme intelligence and trapped him in
the negative zone meanwhile on earth
former avenger rick jones uses these
bands clinks them together to trade
places with captain marvel just like
these two women are swapping places so i
think carol was in possession of the
other bangle the long lost one assuming
these bengals are creetech and that the
ten rings are creetech the pulsing
beacon of the ten rings could have been
summoning the kree empire to earth to
acquire the second bank
oh well said rick
do we agree
because this is the first time i think
in all of history i'm going on the
record as
i agree
i agree 100 with him i agree completely
so you think uh kamala's now trapped in
the negative john i i love that i love
the idea of that i love that her and uh
while carol danvers was in the negative
zone she's just like oh
there who's there i love that and that
being the entrance to the marbles love
it i love it her having to get out of
there go back together to go get her i
love it also i
lo i just i was writing that it was the
cree tech but i was like oh these are
the tech so i like that he was like
these are the mega bands and we're
getting into the nega bands and now we
are uh
cohesively putting them together with
chunky
so i'm like
yeah give me more of that give me more
you guys know she's my favorite i was
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah he loves you some
ten rings i love ten rings do we uh i
love seven rings the ariana grande song
i love the song i want it i got it i
want it i got it i want it i got it
bully him
i'm not touching it
no
keep your face away from my finger
that's not how it works
i just like to be touched do we think
that carol does have the second bangle
right now
well it is weird that she wasn't holding
it when she swaps places right but if it
is like trapped in the neck this whole
like second bengal mcguffin i thought we
would see it by the end of the series
but we never did
uh and even in the flashback uh the
grandma the great grandma didn't even
have both right right right it was just
the one that was in the temple and they
don't know where the other one is it's
not they're not gonna do some playoff it
is the ten rings right they're not gonna
be like one was a bang one was
i was stuck on this i don't know if this
is true that's why i'm bringing it to
this table do we know if that's
how far the timeline was between chiang
chan um miss marvel because i thought
that that was carol danvers at the end
of shanghai where they're all talking
about the ten rings because she looks
exactly the same so i was like does she
jump from there to this now yeah i think
in my post-credits scene she does have
the full sleeve yeah
and i guess like that suit she has is
magic for for like a fair word uh so i
there she could maybe like program it to
not have sleeves when she's feeling like
oh like flies back to the future
adjustable jacket
someone asked a really good question in
the chat that i like of um selva says
how will monica get involved because if
it does go that route where these two
are just walking places do you think on
earth she's like i need to reach someone
and she goes and finds monica well i
think if she she would go and talk to
nick right that's who she trusts the
most and nick's probably with monica now
yeah and i love your whole thing you
keep bringing up that you think monica
is ready to throw
they might not go to it because it is a
very dark place but i do think uh
bigger terms uh she wasn't there to help
her mom carol danvers wasn't there to
help monica's mom and when monica's mom
died she was nowhere in sight but i
think it's farther than that and i think
that uh carol danvers had something with
her mom getting cancer um i had
something to do yeah because even if it
wasn't the powers that carol danvers
exuding i think they both were that she
worked in a high she was in high
position she's going to space all the
time maybe they interacted with stuff
that they weren't supposed to be
interacting with that harmed monica's
mom and she now has this like resentment
towards carol dancer yeah because her
mom keeps working with shield or
whomever
and continues on and so maybe yeah
whatever she's exposed to eventually
like leads to her death and
pissed about it you never came back you
were supposed to be my cool aunt carol
you never came back you never came back
my mom's dead my mom
came back they asked uh could we or do
you think monica has been off training
and i completely yes 100 i think she is
prepared it's monica's mo that's what
she did in one division she was always
ready to go i think she's been training
this entire time and now that carol's
come back she's like well look what the
cat is drunk
every
time she's going back
and talk over
um so do you think we're going to see
the negative zone in the marvels
i hope so i think so i think maybe
prevalently i think this will be the
introduction to it could the the nord
dimension be the negative zone i would
love that
they just didn't call it that that's
their name for it but like it's the
negative it could be a fun reveal yeah
some call it the nor others call it
the negatives i mean they just don't
know
they've done so many weird like
dimensions and planes and
all they keep adding new ones and not
going back to ones they already have
yeah so i would like the negative zone
to be something we're already aware of
in some sort of weird fashion
uh
yeah i don't know because in theory
carol could just leave her it's not like
she's stuck on earth now right she could
just fly away yeah if she wants to but
yeah is she gonna use people on earth
help to get back to the negative zone i
think the bengal helped her get to the
negative zone though so now she can just
jump back without it i think she's gonna
need everybody on deck for some
situation like this uh i i love boss's
theory go watch the full breakdown yeah
i'm on the channel now yeah it just yeah
i went up right before we started right
um and i completely agree which is
i never agree with anyone so
she's a real hater i'm not a hater you
call her
let's talk about we've had a lot of
great super chats today from all you
breakers out there
let's see what a couple of these say uh
andrew anderson asking if you won't give
me a job working for new rock stars and
we never will uh can you just roast me
uh yeah andrew anderson the reason we
won't give you a job is cause you're
garbage you're trash
maybe you can get a job putting yourself
in a glad bag and hurling yourself into
the back of a dump truck
hey he asked he has to be roasted he has
to be honest
if he can't
michael b gave 20 bucks said when do you
guys think we'll next see any mutants
and what do you think we'll see any
x-men
in it
uh we do talk about this on roku
i think i think they're gonna have some
of she-hulk that's why they wanted to do
that
because that'll just watch rogue theory
because i thought we had some good stuff
some good predictions
and brandon and i are on it i know we're
all on it brandon said brandon said
jessica if you come back to this show
i'm gonna kick you in the neck
brandon he's the real bully
uh yes thank you
um
israel velasco saying maybe miss marvel
is both a mutant and an inhuman again we
talked about that on rogue theory this
week uh no the humans are gone forever
sayonara buddy and i say there's always
money to be made in the inhuman stand
it's like bananas
that's a great decade of
oh that just really put reality there uh
spammer and saying my housemates would
love him but tommy's reverse psychology
yielded goals
uh sean bell sending in the super chat
who is your x-men live action lineup
team i would love the 97 animated series
it seems like they're hyping that team
to come also
gambit live action yes yeah i mean if
they don't let our boy channing team
yeah
just let him do what the poor boy wants
to do if it was
uh i will say if they don't have jubilee
if you bring up jubilee one more time
jubilation lee guys
do her right uh mixed man asking saying
i need jessica to cuss me out and tell
me happy birthday
happy birthday you stupid [ __ ]
oh my god
oh no that's too cool you can't you
can't be so mean to someone on their
birthday
folks tomorrow's the big day for tommy
i don't know if i'm even gonna commit to
washing my hair around making it easier
to cut someone's chat said your hair was
a wig they don't think it's real
and this is all really 100 percent
really good
no glue or anything uh
we're going to make it a wig yeah we're
gonna make it a wig baby they might have
misunderstood my comment where i said i
want a tommy wig
i think they said i think what they were
saying is tommy has a beard and that is
true in two
ways in that classic hollywood way uh
spector knight in the comments saying
bring in more for the x-men please bury
my boy more and kill him yeah
please if they do not recreate this is
for more they do not recreate uh
wolverine crying over morph dying i am
gonna be so i think they're gonna do
that which will piss me off i think
they're gonna do that with um who is uh
what's his name that swallowed the in
um that swallowed the lava and he could
turn oh uh darwin darwin
what's gonna happen to darwin there
we've been asking to like let darwin
live and they're like yeah we're gonna
put him in this movie and he's gonna do
and our other two members uh darwin and
more they're gonna walk in a sentinel
just gonna yeah step up
you're all dead justice for bishop too
oh yeah bishop so maybe so many x-men to
choose from so little time uh and so a
little time with all of you who we want
to thank for being with us today thank
you guys for joining us here on the
break room uh it's been a great thursday
night
tommy please do not get on landscape
when i'm serious
it's up to all you fine folks out there
thank you for joining us on the break
room today and every day this week we'll
see you here tomorrow live from our
headquarters here at new rockstars at an
undisclosed location have a great rest
of your thursday later skaters bye-bye
adios goodbye